[Music]
whoa
yeah they do look like ironically the
opposite of earthworms cloud worms this
cloud is one of the world's rarest
weather events they look like giant sky
worms or jet exhaust but they're
completely natural
johnny how you going yeah yourself yeah
i'm one of the handful that have been up
there and got to fly this weather
phenomena called the morning glory cloud
it's a rare phenomena that happens
in australia
in the gulf of carpentaria everyone i
know that's flowing it has had the same
look on their face when they come back
from flying it so i was like i need to
experience that in my life surfing the
morning glory is not for the
faint-hearted only a dozen gliders have
ever attempted it
they describe it as a tsunami in the sky
so it's it's this big rolling wave cloud
in the front of this cloud is is all
this lifting air so you're able to saw
the front of this
this cloud mass that stretches from
horizon horizon those who can't stay in
front get sucked into the whitewash the
equivalent of a wipeout the downwash on
the other side of the cloud is
you know can reach speeds of 2000 feet
per minute it's very very terrible and
your glider is bouncing around you can't
see what's going on because you're in
the cloud sometimes you come out you
don't know which way you're facing or
anything like that what does it feel
like when you're up there
for me it was feeling
how small i was against this cloud i
felt like i was this little spark
against a 2000 foot ski jump yeah it was
certainly nothing i'm going to forget in
my lifetime
these beauties are found in the gulf of
carpentaria a place called mungabai
burke town land in the local language
they're called mabunta hi marindu have
you ever flown the morning glory no no
i'm silly but i'm not actually yeah they
come from far off just a giant long
perfect tubular cigar totally unbroken
rolls over you within minutes
as it passes through you and it
literally does like being at some rock
concert in the base hitting you when
you're close to the speakers it
literally goes through your body it's
truly magical in ganga litagarawa
culture the cloud has a powerful
presence comes along and resets things
picks up recently deceased people
spirits and terrorism along with it up
to the milky way it's a way for them to
travel to where they've got to go its
arrival also signifies changes in the
natural world we know that when the
systems are rolling in that the sea
turtle are starting to nest and that
heavy jew is going to come so it's also
a time for some burns far more than than
just a cultural supernatural thing it's
also a scientific indicator so can you
give us a tour of [ __ ] bay let's have a
look it's a nice little community it's
april today april it's very flat country
out here as you can
see in a second
they roll in from the north
heading behind me to the south they're
also from the east there i reckon the
mid 70s scientists have been coming here
so we started to understand that white
science finds it um as fascinating as us
i've managed to track down one of those
scientists
it's basically uh
two flows of air coming in and colliding
and causing uplift that is the initial
trigger to a morning glory occurring the
gulf of carpentaria is one of a few
places where weather can conjure this
phenomenon it sets up these unique
conditions whereby
you can have two sea breezes coming from
completely different directions
occurring and colliding somewhere in the
middle and that creates atmospheric
waves these waves of kinetic energy give
the clouds their shape
at the crest moist air rises then cools
converting moisture into cloud
on the descending side of that wave
water particles evaporate again so that
gives us that the formation of that
round sling drink or shaped cloud
on the right day a morning glory can
stretch for hundreds of kilometers it's
a pretty incredible phenomenon how do
you rate it oh i think they're probably
the most
eerie and exciting in a way
because they're so large they're so
huge that they're so close to the ground
they're breathtaking they're beautiful
the locals used to say if if there's a
lot of condensation on the beer fridge
in the pub there's a good chance of
having the morning glory the next day
good old town
[Music]
all
cup
you